here he is the man on behalf of the
fedex air and ground
players of the year award that'll be
given out the night before the super
bowl
the man who was darn near 500 yards
clear
of the next rusher on the season rushing
yards list
he is derek henry the tennessee titans
how are you derek
how are you doing i'm doing well so um
let's let's start i guess with um
how you thought your year one let's go
uh open-ended right here to start things
off how'd you think you're you went
derek uh he was good but uh
he wasn't good enough we ain't in super
bowl so it was all right
so that's how you measure the season
when it all comes down to it
be up okay
well i mean i guess what did happen in
your last game
for you uh they played better they were
the better team they played better
on all three places and we didn't do
enough or play well enough to win and
they did so that's why they win the game
so how did they i guess get you on the
turf
uh more successfully this time around
than than the last time in the playoffs
they're more physical skills with the
game um the physical team
prior to being a physical team and they
just played better more political team
and you know they had a plan and they
executed it
okay and so um this season though
for you personally uh do you take any
regard regarding that and just sit back
and say you know
you got in the 2000 yard club derek i
mean that's pretty damn significant
you know oh well i mean as far as us as
a whole
um very uh very special for
you know seeing my teammates um you know
everybody
on the offense that made that happen
from the o-line to
tighten and receive the full backs um
those guys walking for me to
have success it was a cool moment to
have with them and you know
to be able to accomplish that i mean
only
eight people who've done it so it's
definitely a unique company but
i'm motivated you know
can't wait to uh get to work and get in
the off-season
and get ready for next year eric henry
here on the rich eisen show your
fellow nominees for player of the year
at the running back position dalvin cook
and alvin kamara
what do you like about those guys
um albert can do it um on the ground
and receiving um he's been doing it he
came in the league
very deserving for the award and
david cook like sonic is explosive
run through you run by you make you miss
just a hell of a player and um like i
said
all three of us are very deserving and
um
you know they all been following this
season
and um happy for them to get recognized
as well
so uh who would you pay hard-earned
american dollars to watch run the
football
derrick those two guys who else who else
would you pay to run watch
run the football in the nfl all the
things i mean
i mean all all the backs that you know
that have been playing at uh a high
level i mean i can go on and on listen
on those guys and everybody else um
christian uh taequan
uh zeke uh
[Music]
i don't wanna miss chubb um
even kareem i mean i can go on and on
about
uh i mean the the whole list james
robertson he
had a phenomenal year of being on draft
affiliation and coming and
coming in and do what he did this year
josh jacobs
i mean i i can keep going if you want me
to well yeah i do no i i guess
it's pretty cool to pound the table here
in the so-called passing league that you
had somebody like yourself with 2 000
yards rushing
um and you you actually if that game
went into overtime
um you could have set the single season
and um
also single game rushing records in the
same game
do you uh have some sort of
you know i guess chip on your shoulder
to remind everybody how important this
part of the nfl is despite we're talking
about 300 yard 400 yard passers and
things like that
derek i just take uh
take pride in doing my job and
being efficient and being consistent in
my play each and every week trying to
play at a high level to do what i can to
you know help uh help the team and you
know and um
so i'm going there and uh trying to gain
yards and
you know um get in the end zone and
i make sure i prepare each every week to
do those type of things and i know guys
on um off the side of the ball take
pride in that as well
make sure that um we're doing what we
can and being efficient as we can
running the ball each and every week
okay
so um what makes a good stiff arm
derrick henry what makes a good stiff
farm
but what makes a good spit farm if if
it's not a meme
or it's not videos and
different things all over the internet
it's probably not a good step okay so
it's it it's uh i i guess it's kind of
like my business
clicks likes right that's those are the
metrics about a good video for me
is the number of people who watch it
retweet it
so that's it's the same thing is what
you're saying for stiff arms
yeah but yeah i mean like as long as you
ever step on medu
and then keep running to gain yours and
it's it's a good step for them but
sometimes
i can have a good stiff arm and i run
myself out of bounds because i'm
so focused on stiff arm and the guy in
front of me well i mean sometimes also i
guess to equate it as well
you know whenever i play poker i feel
the need whenever i you know
beat somebody and take a bunch of their
money
especially professor's a friend i do
apologize i do even say like i'm sorry
just a little bit do you ever apologize
just at some point just know
how you have stolen another man's soul
uh when they are somebody's son
or somebody's father and you go up to
that person and just
basically even go up and say hey i
understand that was
that was a lot but you or you don't ever
acknowledge that
with somebody who i understand i just
say it's all in love with the game
never personal it's just business yeah i
mean yet josh
norman this year i think is the one that
you memed i believe
this year yeah it is business this is
business
well unless it was earl thomas in last
year's playoffs right
um derek that was kind of personal
wasn't it
that's another person though i mean i've
seen earl uh
um after aft after that and you know got
to talk to him just me
that's all in love with the game i said
another person with this business is all
this
okay if i could give you a choice to
hurdle a guy or stiff arm the guy and
keep running which is your choice
derrick
you know i'm gonna want to step on and
do it i'm doing it aggressively so you
know
can you hurdle someone aggressively i
don't know that that's just more grace
i think pretty much you know what's so
funny is like i've been
i don't know i i probably had the
opportunity but i i i want to hurt her
it's going to come
they have an issue next year i will
hurry up so remember this conversation
okay okay very good i like that derek
henry here
uh at any point during these playoffs
watching brady
uh did you sit there at any point saying
i thought i took care of this guy last
year
i thought i thought we were done with
this guy um
but now he's back in the super bowl how
are you viewing his uh
ride right now derek oh
yeah i mean uh we definitely know what
type of play he is when it comes
down to to the playoffs and you know he
went to camp for wrong reasons
to get to the super bowl and you know
tom brady tom brady his resume speaks
volumes so
you know it was i'm sure it wasn't no
surprise
to nobody to see tom brady back to the
super bowl how many times he's been like
10 times i mean
it is that's a fact they are very
familiar super bowl of tom brady are
very
great friends they are very good friends
they go way back
sort of like your alma mater in national
championships too but i'll get to that
in a second
how do you how do you see super bowl 55
playing out
derek obviously you know taking on the
chiefs very well in a playoff game
uh and how difficult it is to to beat
them and you also know how it is to face
them
regular season how do you derek henry
break down super bowl 55 and who wins it
um i think it's gonna be a great game um
i think uh you know they are
a little bit familiar with each other
because they played each other earlier
this year
kind of the same scenario chiefs were
away team and kevin played play home but
not the super bowl so
um you know different circumstances but
um
you know i think kevin blake has been
playing lights out on defense
um and they've just been building up
building off each other on both sides of
the ball
really on all three phases the chiefs on
with me is
i mean we all know who they are and um
you know type of style that they play i
think it's gonna be a great game that's
gonna be a
really good super bowl but i mean how
can you go against um
iranian champs and that i mean the
office is so exposed to us and
you know i think they they do a great
job as well so i mean
i'm going to random chips but those
those linebackers for tampa haven't they
really come on strong those two got
i mean you know
sound strong they they they have been
bald
evan white has been involved in a lot of
david on the david he's involved as well
so
i mean it's going to be a great one but
i will take the rain this year what's
the hardest you've been here derek
in a game who's hit you the hardest in
your career professional college anybody
has anybody given you that hit um
i mean i've been hit pretty hard a
couple of times
last year uh zach cunningham
caught me one time pretty good so okay
all right and then i guess before i let
you go derek um
desean watson has apparently requested a
trade finally from the houston texans
your thoughts on
maybe not seeing him twice a year now in
your division
it's better for us i wish him uh
well i know the shawn was from the best
and whatever you know occurs
uh uh during this whole situation but
that's that's that's great news for us
but to see what i see here
so uh go to nfl.com fedex
right on twitter at nfl or on the nfl
mobile app
voter voting can is going on right now
closes
next tuesday at three eastern time and
uh i guess
you are here on behalf of the entire
award
do you pound the table for yourself here
or
just what derek is that how it goes for
this
oh i do i mean i mean i would definitely
like to bring
um the trophy home for the second year
in a row
nice all right like i said other guys i
really deserve them
for the award but um i would definitely
like to bring
that trophy home and be able to have
the opportunity again and bolton ends on
tuesday february 2nd
thank you brought at nfl.com fedex if
you want to vote for me i
definitely um appreciate it you'll
accept it
earlier today i got to uh uh on behalf
of fedex and being a partner with them
uh spend time with some health care
workers and they've been
they put heroes in here in this
community and i'm gonna talk with them
and uh
get to know them and spend some time let
them ask me questions
and then i actually uh found out that
the when i wanted
uh player of the week around play of the
week uh i was able to
uh they're able to deliver five uh
backpacks
on the the medical backpacks uh to local
communities and clinics which i thought
that was very cool
because fedex is um donating twenty
thousand dollars
to direct relief on behalf of the air
and ground
players for uh running back and
quarterback so it's a great thing fedex
is doing and
glad to be here on behalf of fedex and
talking to my guy rich
there you go i appreciate it so uh
before i let you go i'll let you pound
the table here
ingram henry jacobs drake uh
there's already a harris in the league
right um here comes another one what do
they all have in common these running
backs
might be missing one or two rbu we all
have coming
dammit it's rvu there ain't no question
if any anybody questioned it it should
be over
and done with the situation nfl
rbu nfl rbu running back university
what's the most you ever pissed off nick
saban before i let you go
what's the one you oh
i've had a moment whenever
uh out of alabama we you know he got
pretty mad at me
what happened uh
i think we were uh we should do a a
period we do team run and
um uh kiffin was still there at that
time too i think it's my last year and
uh
um team run it's like it's like it's
like
that's that period during practice like
game day is the one off
oh one is going to get ones on offers
and defense and
i think we had got like three or four
runs in
and i was the only one doing the reps
and we we were killing the defense
and uh i think joseph was was mad on how
the defense was uh
playing um against against us on that
team running he started period over and
i was gassed
i was like oh my god i'm like man
somebody just gotta come in here
i was like i was like hey can somebody
else come with nobody else available
because it was like you know he he was
on me
and told me to be quiet and get back in
there and
and finish the rep so that was the one
time my favorite
really got on to me so i guess you uh
pissed him off because of how good you
were against the defense
and then he needed you to bring the same
energy
when he restarted the period because of
how bad
you made the defense look and you said
you
you were you were gassed or you were
indicating that and that's what pissed
him off even more
so it was all about basically basically
he was saying stop crying for making
excuses get your butt back in there
and run the ball again see if you can do
it again
and did you i i
i think i had a pretty good success i
think they
played a little better but i still had a
little bit success i don't know if i was
i was able to breathe but i know i got
through it well i guess that's coaching
and then you've got a heisman trophy on
the case for it
hey derek thank you for uh for the call
i guess congrats on all your success i
do love talking to you so
uh don't we won't lose this number and
you don't uh
uh lose it as well appreciate it derek
congrats on all your success
appreciate you right back at you that's
at king henry underscore two on twitter
at last underscore king underscore two
on instagram on behalf of the fedex air
and player of the year awards to be
given out
uh at the nfl honors the night before
the super bowl
voting closes tuesday february 2nd at 3
p.m eastern
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here